all right thank you very much no really
I appreciate that I know why you're
excited we're back on the air it's a new
year it's a leap year did you know that
it's a leap year we get one extra day I
thought I heard that I thought oh that's
great then I remembered oh one more day
of Trump versus Biden
no thanks what
no yeah I guess that that race is kind
of over uh Trump won big in Iowa they
had the Iowa caucuses that had on Martin
Luther King
day uh what better way to honor Martin
Luther King than the whitest state in
the nation voting for a guy who's going
to take you back to the 1950s this
is well I mean come on well you saw uh
Nikki Hy came in third uh you sure
what history buff Nikki
uh she said this has never been a racist
country
never I mean we can argue never really I
mean this is someone who goes by Nikki
uh because she have used her real name
no one in her party would vote for her
but it's
not
uh and uh the other uh indian-american
in the race V ramaswami he dropped out
uh dropped out of the race and admitted
he is Sasha Baron Cohen so
that's I thought
that right he was the uh he was the
youngest candidate at at 38 now it's
it's going to be you know 82 versus 78
the oldest oldest combined number of
years we've ever had running uh although
Trump was braging this week he said he
feels like a 35y old he he said this uh
he owes it to his Fitness routine
uh
really he says every morning he does 100
brain f
Mar